let's start the afternoon session of
this glorious reinforced abiding day so
we're very very happy to have failed
shipments from Google policy
optimization hey thanks
so maybe to set the context a bit I'm
gonna try something actually quite
simple so this is not a theory
presentation there will be you know a
theorem or something really the point of
it I think the point of what I'm trying
to do here is sort of advertise I think
a lot of missed opportunity both
algorithmic and theoretical really down
in the sub-basement of reinforcement I
think well actually they they'll just
launch into so let me sort of establish
context by starting with this big
picture we all know this picture this is
the single most dangerous picture in all
of AI the reason this is a dangerous
picture is it makes the reinforcement
learning problem looks so simple right
there's just these two boxes a couple
arrows aging environment seems like
there should be an easy problem and and
the deception here is is that in in this
picture you can embed you know pretty
much all of AI you can embed a
staggering array of very complex very
difficult subproblems and I have to
admit I was I was supremely impressed
this morning with a lot of the
theoretical progress on tasks that I'm
gonna shortly show you are sort of in
the middle range of complexity in the
story that maybe even overreaching some
beyond some of the more basic things
that I still think we haven't nailed
down so here's what I mean imagine if
you're reductionist and we want to start
to decompose this this overall problem
into a couple of sort of key tangible
subtasks well you know here's here's an
attempt at breaking it down you know
when I said agent an environment I
didn't say anything about the
environment for example the environment
could have other agents in it the other
agents could be aware of the presence of
your agent there could be things then
that happened like non-stationarity x'
due to coalitions and cooperation and
competition normally when we put that
diagram up there you're not even
thinking about that but multi agent
interaction is ad
an overwhelming challenge it's not even
clear in all cases what a solution
concept really is if you eliminate that
and say no no it's a cold oblivious
universe to the presence of the agent
it's just got to deal with physics you
know we still have the sense the
perception problem the partial
observability task could be a very
complex universe so our agent needs to
now construct memories to allow to
disambiguate its current perceptual
state from situation in your mind right
now your context all your commitments
things you need to know and so on and so
forth they're not listed in front of you
they're constructed memories based on
your past experience these are the
critical memories you need to build in
order to act effectively in the universe
so partial observability isn't
acknowledged you know sort of what I
started to realize though is that like
textbook reinforcement learning the
thing we presume we're talking about
Markov decision processes is add a
pretty intermediate level of complexity
and I'm pretty impressed with the heroic
efforts to understand how to solve
problems at this level and everything
below but I want to kind of take us down
a level so what's interesting is that
bat reinforcement learning is somehow
now an emerging problem where what we do
is we take sort of the Markov decision
process problem and we remove the
responsibility of the agent to deal with
the exploration exploitation trade-off
simply an exploitation problem perhaps
we give you data or simple model we just
ask you to produce an optimal behavior
strategy even here things are not that
simple for example we immediately
encounter the temporal credit assignment
problem perhaps in data you have to now
figure out or attribute you know which
of the sequence of decisions were the
critical ones if any or all that's in
the retrospective view prospectively we
now have to deal with this kind of short
term versus long term
I'm actually going to mostly talk about
the thing that's below that beneath our
attention the pure policy optimization
question that comes up when we're not
even dealing with you know bellman
consistency concepts but just
straight-out optimization on one-step
decision-making it's at this level
actually where most of the connection to
the rest of machine learning resides and
I'm gonna try to make a case that a lot
of the obvious connections are really
fruitful here and they're kind of
missing in most of what we're thinking
about in this area so I just want to
kind of close the gap there and see if I
can inspire some I will come back up to
sequential decision making at the end
and try to explain a bit about what
we're thinking there based on what we
can understand okay so I'm just gonna
start out by actually doing this in a
very simple way here is a very basic
problem that actually students to the
field probably are presuming we already
know how to solve
it's the batch policy optimization
problem in contextual bandits so imagine
I just give you a set of data or a set
of context like x1 to XM where let's
even assume they're iid you know
contacts from some stationary
distribution let's simplify further
assume we have like a finite set of
actions a1 2 a.m. and our data consists
simply of the natural thing which is you
know in context one we tried action a2
and we saw reward 1 and that's all we
saw in context and so on and so forth so
we've observed one action in each
context and our task is simple we just
on the basis of this data need to
produce a good policy and what do we
mean by good policy here well let's
let's say what we mean is what we mean
in the rest of machine learning or at
least classical supervised learning is
we're interested in a policy whose
expected reward on future data outside
of this data set right is as high as
possible so the generalization question
is the central question in this case
and yep so just to make sure I
understand whether you're sort of more
in a cosmic time setting or not do we
know the decision room there yeah yeah
that it's coming yeah at times yes at
times no but it will be clear from
context so anyway just to kind of build
up intuition so yes I think that you
know there's these basic issues that we
face here actually this problem is quite
subtle
so maybe just to again engage your
intuition a bit by optimizing say we
have a parametric policy class by you
know manipulating the parameters of that
policy class what are we doing well
we're changing the policy changing the
policies is essentially in this data
shifting the mass you know into various
different you know column locations in
each row so what we want to do you know
when we're training at least we think
about is how are we shifting the mass
the policy support you know in this data
set to maybe you know land on high
reward at you know high observed rewards
maybe avoid low observe rewards and you
can start to see there's a lot of risk
here and there's a lot of subtlety for
example if all the rewards are the same
that's not interesting maybe you simply
want to move all your mass onto the
observed data well that's simply just
relearning the behavior strategy
assuming that was a stationary behavior
strategy assuming that it was a good
strategy and I never said it was a good
strategy ideally what you want to do is
actually you know optimize the policy to
do better in expecting reward than the
data collection
yeah one moment he shot and so in the
extreme you might say well there's a
largest observed reward here right we
want to move mouse on to that and may
even sacrifice moving mouse off the rest
but you can see the danger which is now
if we move most of the mass off the
support of the data we have almost no
statistical evidence to support much
simpler more than it's a full
observability it's coming okay
so so here's what I'm gonna attempt to
do to organize the discussion is I'm
gonna focus on these two sort of sub
bullets here which is normally machine
learning we think about like an
optimization process to optimize the
policy the parameters of the policy okay
so I'm actually gonna go in some depth
about how we consider what the
optimization objective should be and
then the other obvious issue here is the
missing data problem right like we have
all of this you know missing data and
how we reasoning about that missing data
or you know what inferences we're making
explicitly or implicitly about missing
data is actually quite essential okay
now before I actually start decomposing
this there is an elephant in the room
and it's kind of like the default answer
there's another one but this is sort of
the first primary default answer which
is we already know how to do this right
all we got to do is like assume we've
logged the behavior of the proposal
probabilities of whatever the data
collection process was and then simply
you know do a simple importance
correction like recorrect you know
dividing by the inverse x inverse
propensity the policy probability times
reward that gives us an unbiased
estimate of expected reward expected
reward is what we want to optimize so
we've answered both questions we know
what our optimization objective should
be and we know how we should be dealing
with missing data this research was
motivated by the observation that this
is a very poor answer to both of those
questions and if this is a poor answer
to those questions what might a good
answer look like and what is surprising
is in both cases
our answers to this question are already
well-known in things we already have
studied quite a lot in for example
supervised learning in other areas so I
just first want to connect this up to
things we already know and and we
already understand better ways to
approach this phone okay so let me start
with the how do we formulate an
optimization objective or a reasonable
principle by which we want to tune the
policy parameters and then I'll get to
missing data so first optimization
objectives so yes indeed so to isolate
the task with simplified okay fully
observe data so I give you a complete
table we've seen every will reward
counterfactual we for every action every
context and we're interested in
maximizing the expected reward now I'll
remind you what we're interested in is
not the expected reward on the data
we're really interested in the expected
reward in future data but you know this
is sort of our target objective and we
could imagine now without even having to
do importance correction that this is
all we do problem solved this is the
objective and we just optimize this okay
and the observation is is that we've
missed something here and it turns out
and actually Alec already pointed out
that this is a fundamentally poor
optimization objective it's actually an
incredibly bad way to train your policy
in the fully observed case so there's no
variance to deal with either and we're
in trouble and I was going to explain
why we're in trouble but I think Alec
already explained it is that normally
when we parameterize a policy we're
gonna produce some mapping you know some
neural net or Cynthia Maps context to
ask or vector across actions that gets
converted to a policy through the
softmax transfer we as potentiate scores
we renormalize produce a probability
vector that's the policy okay the
problem is here sorry
this inner product between the reward
vector in a given context and the policy
probability vector in the given context
has to go through this softmax that
inner product in that softmax transfer
interact incredibly poorly for example
with plateaus right so as you
concentrate your probability mass on an
arbitrary action not even a good one the
gradient goes to zero the the landscape
flattens out okay you can even do fun
things like make it worse you can also
embed like local minima or sorry local
Maxima all over the place you can create
interference patterns you can embed like
exponentially many local Maxima on this
surface it's in fact hard to just to
create a harder optimization surface
that's still smooth it's differentiable
its plateaus everywhere and you can
create like you know arbitrarily
complicated landscapes to the training
yes that's true it's also erm where
we're using this classification yeah
coming to that right away in fact that's
the next thing I want to say is we
already know we don't train this way
what I mean by this is well let's
imagine we look at a further special
case which is what if it just so
happened that the rewards are 0-1
rewards where there's a single one in
each column which is a correct class
label right so you get a reward of one
if you get the correct class label
reward of zero otherwise now our
expected word objective is
classification accuracy okay and how do
we train a supervised model to you know
both fit in terms of classification
accuracy and perhaps generalize to new
data well what we don't do is optimize
our dot pi what we do and what we teach
all of our students to do is to maximize
our log pi naught r dot pi right we use
surrogates in fact we use it so often we
don't even think to not use surrogates
and what's remarkable here of course is
that our da pie objective is perfectly
differentiable like you change one you
know we've changed your loss function
and tensorflow we rerun the experiment
there's nothing preventing you from
doing this other than the fact that it
just doesn't work very well it's a you
know intractable optimization we on the
other hand by looking at log loss what
have we done we've created a surrogate
objective that is now convex at least in
the top layer the score layer it is
actually related to the original Mis
classification loss that in the you know
if we have enough capacity the global
minimizer if you can reach it in the in
the r dot log pi is the same as the
global Maximizer in the R so we preserve
the global Maximizer we've now created a
convex optimization service this is such
a natural thing to do in supervised
learning that we have forgotten to
remind our students that when we're
measuring this classification error on
training and test data but that was the
target loss that you could have chosen
as a training loss but you don't choose
that because it's untrainable what's
remarkable to me is to see that this
lesson now is instantly forgotten the
moment we start to remove some of the
data okay anyway but just to close the
loop on this so we understand that
supervised learning you use surrogates
to make the training problem reasonable
and and yet still we have a fully
developed like generalization theory so
it doesn't preclude reasonable theory oh
just for the sake of argument I ran the
experiment the yellow line is training
with expected reward and there's
plateaus and hills actually the other
way to understand the difficulty with
the r dot pi objective through the
softmax transfer is when you look at
that softmax transfer if you had a
temperature parameter we took scores
divided by temperature then
exponentiated normalized take that
temperature in the zero temperature
limit your landscape is now piecewise
constant right so it really is plateaus
everywhere 0 gradient everywhere and
then you're just searching this hole
the landscape all that's happening by
moving the temperature away from zero is
that we're adding a little bit of shape
but it turns out the real optimization
landscapes are virtually plateaus
everywhere and you can see here you're
caught in some Plateau you think it's
converge and then out of nowhere you
drop and then you're caught in some
other plateau and I've run this there's
only goes up to 200 I've run this
thousands like it never it's it looks
the same but the policy gradient trick
is relying on a non policy distribution
and this is by the way can be all off
policy but yeah it's related sure the
answer is yes okay so okay let me just
sort of close the loop in a general case
of course that's what we kind of know
what to do in the zero one reward case
which is we just do our dot log pie but
what if R is general like not zero one
loss it isn't much trickier but actually
that was sort of a more recent finding
so Chabot and Bernardo and I think
others have shown that indeed you can
construct like you know convex
calibrated surrogate objectives for the
general cost sensitive what I just
wanted to share with you briefly is that
actually once you start thinking of like
constructing surrogate objectives it's
pretty easy to come up with reasonable
ones I happen to like this kind of
entropy regularize trick which has
already come up several times today if
we look at expected reward we just add a
bit of entropy regularization with a
towel parameter we have bias the results
okay the optimal policy has now been
shifted away from a one hot like a
deterministic policy to a slightly more
diffused one but the bias can be
completely controlled by Tao what we
gained though is a really intuitive
natural access to a whole space of
plausible reasonable effective surrogate
objectives for example if you have
entropy regularize expected reward that
is equivalent to minimizing a and KL
divergence between your policy output
and an implicit probability a target
distribution that we never mentioned I
think it came up this morning which is
simply the exponentiated reward disk
so you know for Towel regularization
optimizing the top objective is the same
as while creating artificial target
distribution by dividing the rewards by
tau this still fully observed
exponentiating normalizing calling that
a distribution measuring Kayle okay now
this has not changed landscape problems
but by looking at it from a KO lens we
now see really really obvious ways to
develop other surrogate objectives like
for example flip the KL around flipping
the KL moves from something that is like
you know entropy regularize expect to
reward to something that looks an awful
lot like supervised like log loss and in
fact has much the same character it is
now like convex in the it's also
unbiased in the sense that it has the
same global minimizer is the original
objectives we've preserved we've you
know introduced convexity to landscape
we've preserved the global minimizer we
want to preserve one other problem
property to put some theory but
basically it's a it's a cheap and easy
way and natural way to produce
surrogates just quickly on the side I
won't there's no actually okay I want to
pose it as a question that theoreticians
quickly on the side if you took this and
we went back to the original log loss
case and we compare these two objectives
we'll notice that this reverse KL is
very similar but not identical to the
original like our dot log pi the maximum
likelihood objective the difference is
simply that in the maximum likelihood
objective we have our score vector Q
being inner product with the indicator
of the correct class label and here when
we do the reverse scale the only thing
different is the the inner product is
with respect to this implicit P which is
X that indicator vector divided by tau
exponentiate normalize that P
distribution is not deterministic right
it actually has mass everywhere and so
all that this is done is smooth the
labels and this was a discovery a few
years ago in like mostly an object
recognition context that smoothing the
training labels in maximum likelihood
for whatever reason is giving a
generalization boost I'm aware of no
theory that's justifying or explaining
this but it's actually a pretty
persistent although somewhat small
advantage that people are relying a lot
on practice these days
well one theoretical explanation is that
if you have if you view your labels as
being generated by some target function
you're simplifying the target function
by smoothing it and then you turn that
into a theory yeah cool okay let's see
here ah one further step is to get upper
bounds like to get like sort of risk
bounds and sort of generalization
theories it's it's nice to have so if we
said the entropy regularize expected
reward was a target objective we can
also now construct calibrate a convex
upper bounds on that target objective
and that will come back later that's
sort of a useful way j't these made-up
objectives actually work quite well if
you just sort of replicate like the text
you know this sort of the machine demo
101 scripts and then just plug out log
loss and replace it with the expected
reward that doesn't work but if you do
these surrogates indeed you can train
pretty rapidly and you get
generalization benefits so in practice
this is you know just connecting to what
we already understand them supervised
learning and it's it's beneficial okay
so now let's go back to our L so next
step is well what if the data is missing
so in some sense if we're looking at
this batch contextual bandit
optimization task the only difference
between what we're looking at here and
classical supervised learning is simply
the missing data problem and so I think
the other interesting question is in RL
what tools what thinking what techniques
were we bringing to bear about reasoning
about missing data and and from where
I'm sitting the the answer is kind of
depressing mostly what I'm seeing is
well okay let's start out with very
trivial strategies one way to deal with
missing data is like imputation so you
can imagine you have a model maybe
you've trained it somehow and you just
simply use the model to fill in you know
guesses for all the
right reduce the problem to a fully
observed problem and then deploy
whatever previous techniques this sounds
naive but actually this is the
foundation for what's going on right now
in most approaches and what I mean is
well just let's look at for example
importance directed expected reward if
you look at importance corrected
expected reward is mathematically
equivalent to taking that data filling
in 0 for every guess for everything you
haven't seen taking the things you have
seen and exaggerating them that's what
it does that is probably the worst
missing data inference technique I've
ever encountered it has one benefit
though is that it's unbiased right by
putting zeros everywhere and by like
exaggerating the things we've observed
when we think about expected reward
vectors under the sampling mechanism
right well sure we'll multiply by the
proposal probability will cancel out the
thing we divided by will now instill
this you know one hot vector on the
observed action times award when we add
those up we get the original war vector
so it's unbiased if you're trying to
prove theorems about expectations you
know it makes a lot of sense right it
simplifies your life but in terms of
actual technique right how you're
actually going to train a policy on this
data like I'm sorry
this is committing to pretty weak
technology's a huge difference because
someone gave you the beta and if someone
doesn't give you the beta that's harder
well what people do is they fit you know
they'll presume is from stationery I'll
see and then like train another policy
to fit that policy and then use those
and they argue about the you know the
bias
okay anyway that's not the point I'm
trying to make yet but that's cool
there are you know some obvious
improvements one is okay I'm not
addressing the variance issue here so
this is obviously a high variance or
like a lot of like sensible you know
sophisticated variance reduction
strategies but I actually want to
persist bike drawing connections to the
rest of machine learning but one
intermediate step is you know a mild
improvement which is to actually use a
model other than zero to fill in the
missing data and you can still can
recover unbiasness rather simply by just
you know still exaggerating on the
observed components but not exaggerating
the observed values just exaggerating
the difference between the observed
value and your guests your model
prediction it is better in terms of
variance it's still unbiased it's not
that much more sophisticated but at
least you know it's it's certainly
better than zero
this however allows us to think a little
bit about basic reinforcement learning
techniques and how they relates to
machine learning as follows the model
has to come from somewhere and so you
know you ask yourself the question and
it's like where does the model come from
and it seems like people want to
naturally run into this kind of - model
view where well we started with a policy
some parametric policy representation
that's the object we care about that's
the thing we're trying to produce and
now we need a model to fill in the
missing data that must be a different
model right because it's doing a
different job it's guessing you know
rewards instead of like producing
probability vectors if you think that
way then what happens here is that well
where does that model come from the most
natural thing is that well this is the
only data we had that models trying to
predict Ward's so the natural thing to
do is just regress that model to the
observer Awards and they use that as the
predictor the problem is if you take
that model now we already know what the
optimal policy is for that model it's
either late
predictor or maybe a softmax like an
entry regularize version of that policy
but actor critic thinking in this
one-shot decision-making scenario is
virtually vacuous first of all the value
function is policy independent it's just
the reward function so basically your
critic is just learning the reward
function you could imagine trying to
iterate with some policy improvement you
do your policy improvement and now it's
the same reward function you're at a
fixed point and if you literally take
that model and and use it this is the
direct message method it's not bad it
often does better than importance
correction but it's actually not as you
know an effective technique both in
theory or in practice should just do
Lisa Neil a simple regression to the
observe Awards and then extracted really
balls okay so here's where there was an
opportunity I think we're missing and
I'm trying to somewhat advocate but it's
hard to get people to anyway let me try
it is what if instead we just go back to
thinking like there's only one model
right there's just this one object we're
trying to produce but once we've already
kind of accepted that there's some kind
of relationship between score vectors
and probably you know probabilities that
maybe we could just unify the models and
say we just we have one model that
simultaneously is as a reward estimator
and a policy okay and then that same
model like it just depends whether you
look at the model output before or after
the final final softmax transfer but
it's just that one object I would argue
you gain a lot by unifying things in
this way in particular we now can merge
some of these missing data inference
techniques like doubly robust estimators
with the previous surrogate losses
totally seamlessly maybe it escaped your
attention previously but these surrogate
objectives that we had before were
working both in the space of logits and
in the space of the output distribution
so it was unified before nobody noticed
they you know there's just one model
being optimized everybody seemed happy
and now I removed some data and somebody
we want to have two models and I'm just
pointing out we can go back to one model
it's still coherent and in fact it's it
sounds so I'll try to argue a little bit
that this isn't as made up as it seems
this at least and allows us to think
like fairly flexibly about surrogate
training objectives perhaps motivated by
the fully observed case and combine them
with like reasonable missing data
inference techniques fit them together
they come together in one model and you
get an optimization where for example
you can use like self imputation
strategies okay this works amazingly
well at least in the you know sort of
the typical scenarios people like but
what I want to point out is that it is
actually sound and in some sense and I'm
not gonna this isn't a theory talk so I
don't think I'm gonna drag through
everything but you can take you know
this convex upper bound as a surrogate
objective you can look at the empirical
version of that upper bound we can
define our target objective is the
expected smooth risk and by smooth risk
I just mean the entropy regular and
indeed you know it's just a textbook
exercise to apply things we already know
that as long as you know certain
boundedness things are you know assumed
and we use an unbiased inference
mechanism when you combine these things
you can show yes if you with high
probability if you get a small empirical
like surrogate risk that that does imply
with high probability abound the true
gap in the you know in terms of the
expected smooth risk
okay so it's not you know not completely
arbitrary it allows us to actually just
apply machinery that we already have
lying around cannot we what what what
exactly is the norm across it cannot be
across all the actions because I missing
data as you're pointing out so is it a
normal context what is the space you
know it's interesting in a lot of areas
of machine learning right now when
people complain about non differentiable
objectives what they mean is missing
data yes so this is actually over the
entire vector but what's being used here
is a missing data inference mechanism so
it's a combination of both so I pick an
objective for the fully observed case
this is pretty now you've approached by
anyway I pick an objective from the
fully observed case and I have a bunch
of missing data and then I apply some
missing data inference mechanism that
fills in guesses and I just composed
those two operators yeah there should
probably be hats on it and so on yeah
yeah so the way you applied is you
produce in our there definitely so beta
is like there's certain assumptions
about beta like you know full support
and like a lower bound on the proposal
probabilities this theorem isn't even
going to withstand like infinite action
sets yeah so it's it's it's pretty
rudimentary still but I think but not
vacuous and I think it allows us to to
at least show that this idea of
composing missing data inference with
reasonable objectives is viable just as
a proof of concept
so it's Oh actually one thing I didn't
explain is one shot it's iid so there's
no temporal dependence textual bandit
yeah I'll try to get to time a little
bit but yeah it's sorry it's like I said
it's beneath our attention it's this
problem way way way way down there but I
think that we can see how we can do much
better just by connecting up to things
yeah it's in this like our hat so
everywhere you see an are like a target
vector we're gonna replace it with our
estimated target vector yeah so in here
right so there's a couple units and
inequalities and then some tail I guess
yeah it's kind of buried in here it's I
have a write up like I mean we can go I
think it's more like I'm just I'm not
trying to prove theoretical virtuosity
here I'm just trying to prove proof of
concept and viability that I think it is
actually coherent either according to
your upper bound or maybe at least
intuitively do you have some way to
estimate our hat which significantly
improves upon just filling in zeros
yeah well the doubly robust that's
coming but the theory isn't there for
that yeah okay maybe I'll move on yes
okay yes so this is a composition of a
trivial missing data inference strategy
which is this doubly robust estimator
right we just exaggerated the
differences of the predictions and the
observe rewards otherwise fill in our
model predictions fool ourselves into
thinking that's the true roared function
and then applying the fully observe like
loss functions and then you know the
theory just kind of composes with that
not too much work okay all right now the
other thing I want to observe is that if
we really think hard about missing data
inference this is not a new problem
right no machine learning and and the
other thing is there's there's this
weird kind of disconnect another
disconnect which is the way we think
about missing data inference in RL
versus the way we think about it
elsewhere and I I'll see how this goes
you know one of the natural things to
appeal to normally when we think about
missing data inference is some kind of
generative modeling approach right so
usually when we're teaching classes what
do we do we say here's a graphical model
maybe it's a Bayesian network and then
here you've observed some of the
variables in the model and there's a
bunch of variables you haven't observed
and then you formulate the posterior
distribution over the things you haven't
observed given the things you have
observed right just you know standard
conditional like you know distribution
inference you can apply that here and so
just as a simple more concrete example
you know a slightly more satisfying way
to impugn pharan TSA's about missing
data is not just just to kind of plug in
you know some model guess but to think
you know what if we had some generative
process like maybe some gaussian or some
parametric new parameterize exponential
family where we have a generative
mechanism that takes like the output now
of our neural net which could be instead
of direct guesses like hyper parameters
for some exponential family distribution
that accounts for assumptions about
noise and so on and so forth that when
you see an observation like in a row
here
right we have some prior distribution
over the reward functions in that
context we see that one observation we
got a posterior distribution over the
you know the reward functions in that
context and we'll get a predictive
distributions like a posterior
expectation and so on and so forth now
I'm just using gaussians because this is
of course one of the few cases where all
the integrals are tractable and we get
closed form results but remarkably even
here for continuous action problems you
can use simple Gaussian inference and
it's not the standard approach right now
and I'm puzzled itis so anyway you can
formulate like a prior over reward
functions you get a posterior overlord
functions and now you want to optimize
the model which is the neural net which
is okay let me explain it this way I'm
not saying let's go full Bayes and
suddenly everything's an integral and
then we're just chasing MCMC algorithms
for the rest of the day imagine we just
have this isolated sort of Bayesian
inference only at the top layer of the
network the rest of the network is
optimized just as usual we're only using
Bayesian inference to give us some more
subtlety in the inferences we're making
over the missing observations even under
some simple parametric assumption there
is an interesting question that comes
out of this and I think research
directions that sort of accidentally
spewed out of this the natural way to
optimize the neural network under say
even this kind of Bayesian inference
model would be you know classically
empirical Bayes estimation or maximizing
the marginal likelihood of the observed
data given the you know hyper parameters
that we're producing from enrollment so
they know that's like a big hyper
parameter we're just optimizing it to
you know maximize log likelihood in the
Gaussian case kind of somewhat
embarrassing embarrassingly what we get
is least squares regression which not
long ago I was telling you is a terrible
idea doesn't work that great in practice
okay so actually empirical Bayes is a
little more subtle like it's least
squares regression regression but it's
also doing some inference over the like
the variance scales and so it does
better than naive regression but it's of
the same type but you can start to
imagine like other principle of
reasonable sounding forms of
optimization objective once we have some
sort of Bayesian inference mechanism
for example a couple of things I tried
was actually mapping it back to the
surrogate objective through the fully
observed case where we were essentially
looking at kale divergences between say
a prior se a prior mean distribution and
a posterior or a posterior and a prior
yeah yeah the posterior prior Direction
is particularly interesting because it's
also equivalent to a reasonable estimate
of the mutual information between the
latent parameter and the observed
rewards and we're essentially training
the neural network so that if you could
get zero training loss you've removed
any information dependence between the
observed rewards and the the latent
parameter we're trying to identify which
means there's nothing left to learn from
the data okay anyway it sounds weird
we have no theory that justifies this
yet but actually it works these were
sort of the objectives that work at this
one in particular that worked quite well
in the previous scenarios it actually
also works quite well here and slightly
better than classical empirical Bayes
trying to figure out if this actually
makes sense it seems interesting so this
is at the intersection of both missing
data inference and surrogate training
objectives just a reminder we have not
lost sight of the fact that what we care
about is expect a reward just because we
care about that it doesn't mean we
fixate on that it's the only training
principle oh and it's just you know some
graph it's not as impressive as it
sounds but if you do like importance
corrected to expect a reward
maximization some continuous action
problem you know it's quite poor and if
you use the sort of you know Bayesian
like empirical Bayes variance you get
substantially better it's hard to see
just differences between the empirical
Bayes variance in this example but it
turns out one of the the KL divergence
is is slightly better there's totally
empirical there is no theory yet in
place to justify this so here's the
appeal which is a reminder that Bayesian
estimation is a fine idea it is biased
right we've
from fixating on variance reduction
strategies for unbiased estimates to
something that we know is a biased
estimator and it's therefore harder to
analyze but we also know has principles
and support you know for it that are not
available for a sort of simple
importance corrective estimators and
another reminder which i think is a
healthy reminder for all of us is like
you know Stein shrinkage so you know it
admittedly simple scenarios right you
can prove amazing theorems like if you
do empirical Bayes estimation right for
the mean of a multivariate Gaussian you
can get an estimator that's indeed
biased but has provably better expected
squared prediction error then the
unbiased like maximum likelihood
estimator regardless of truth no matter
where the true mean vector is right you
dominate the the standard unbiased
estimator and so I actually see the open
question here is can we actually pull
something like this off even in a simple
contextual bandit City can we actually
develop estimators hopefully tractable
ones where we can actually prove
domination for example in the expected
it doesn't seem hopeless
maybe not true okay and I'm gonna use
maybe five minutes
v to explain that
okay sequential decision-making so let's
let's just pop up and say okay what if
it's the same scenario except now it's
the sequential decision making problem
what that means is the data is no longer
like this simple matrix where there's a
contact CC single reward let's imagine
it's like a replay buffer we've just
collected a bunch of trajectories maybe
like arm reaching trajectories or robot
navigation trajectories but just a bunch
of natural trajectories where we've
logged like here was a context here was
an action here was the next context and
here was an immediate reward previously
I was quite astonished that we didn't
understand how to like extract good
policies from such data but now I'm not
surprised anymore because we I think
we're struggling to understand how to do
it when there is no sequence but but
anyway let's you know get our confidence
back so imagine now we're looking at
these sequential trajectories and we
want to extract a policy that's both
empirically effective but perhaps also
theoretically justified what's getting
in our way and maybe I'll just say the
most controversial thing now so I can
have some conversations over the coffee
break which is I think the thing that's
been getting in our way and has
distracted us for about 30 years is the
bellman optimality principle now we have
a paper last year where we dive in deep
into the nature of the bellman
optimality principle in the context
where you introduce function
approximation and I think we should all
know by now that those two things do not
fit well together at all okay and I
think you know we finally achieved some
level of understanding where we you know
we understand even algorithmically in
simple scenarios what it would take to
you know deal with bellman you know sort
of bellman relationships or temporal
consistency in value over time and
function approximation and still you
know somehow train the the function
approximator to converge to the optimal
expressible policy not the optimal
policy and no guarantee about the
relationship to the optimal policy but
the optimal achievable policy in your
representation class with no other
assumptions and and we've started to get
on top of that and what did what it
required us to do was to acknowledge
that the bellman optimality principle is
the is the danger
okay so I'll just try to maybe explain
why the bellman optimality principle is
not our friend and then I've got a
couple of bets and and then I'll end so
I mean we know bellman optimality right
like the optimal state action value
function or vector right is just a
satisfies an entire set of nonlinear
constraints right so over the entire
state action space now this set of
constraints is as big as the number of
free variables and it's nonlinear which
means a priori there's no reason
whatsoever there should even be a
feasible solution okay it just so
happens right you know the genius of
Bellman's optimality principle is there
is a there is a feasible solution to
this there's guaranteed to be a feasible
solution but there's only one the
feasible set is a singleton right the
optimal value function that is the only
solution to this system of equations
okay and now we add function
approximation we all know what this
means it means that there is no feasible
set anymore right everything's in
feasible the chances of your function
approximation class has somehow
magically going right through that one
feasible point is you know measure 0
it's just not gonna happen which means
now we're engaged in this over
constrained system and we've got to now
make awkward trade-offs like is this
constraint more important than that
constraint you know how do we deal with
this well unfortunately like a long long
time ago we thought like whoa it's easy
right you just add a penalty function
we'll just like square all those
constraint violations and say well
that's what we're trying to minimize it
makes whatever trade-offs it makes and
we you know we struggle to do this then
we take this objective we pull a
gradient throw and we discover well you
know we get this dolmen residual thing
we've got the double sampling problem
that's awkward
and then heroically you know we can
reduce that to this update where let's
just neglect this and look at the update
this is no longer the gradient of
anything it's an update and in the
tabular case where we're not wrestling
with function approximation amazingly
this update can be proven to work that
to converge if you iterate on this
you'll find fix points and the fixed
points are solutions to this but in the
function approximation case right like
the theory is mostly telling us doesn't
work or it only works under very you
know restrictive
okay I don't want to go through all this
so right now we're kind of investigating
three different attacks on how do you
avoid any bootstrapping in C you know
even in the batch case from extracting
an optimal policy without looking at
double inconsistency okay now one it's a
bit of a cheat which is building on our
paper from last year which is to you
know go down the multiple hypothesis
tracking paths so I think that the key
observation last year is that if you
really really want to you know deal with
the bellman optimality principle under
function approximation and you want to
do this kind of iterative update process
you have to track multiple hypotheses
that is you kind of have to explicitly
track all of the viable hypotheses that
are consistent with your function a
function approximation class and the max
and you'll discover like maybe the max
decision is not consistent with
hypothesis and so you have to kill that
hypothesis and like back up a second Max
and so on and so forth so we're trying
to find practical algorithmic you know
viable approaches that are built on this
multi path assist tracking strategy I
have some bizarre observations about
like just distributional RL and why that
might be working it might also be about
multiple hypothesis tracking but one of
the things I want to point out that
surprised me and is Monte Carlo policy
iteration so this is again beneath us
it's this thing that's so trivial it
gets dismissed every time I mention it
to somebody they go da da da that can't
work and the idea is what if we get rid
of bootstrapping but we have the Monte
Carlo returns right we have the
trajectory so on the trajectories we can
do all the money Carlo inference the
Monte Carlo return is an unbiased
estimate of the behavior policy value
totally unbiased it's of the behavior
policy value if we just took the Monte
Carlo backed up returns and then
optimized the policy to that we're doing
what iteration of policy improvement
right you have a policy you get a value
estimate we improve the policy that's
pretty reliable and it gets even better
if you like use reasonable surrogates
and maybe some reasonable missing data
inference task mechanisms and so this is
just a toy data like cart poll but I
just want to point out that if you do
random walk in cart pole the pole falls
over after 20 steps almost always it's a
very thin tail gamma distribution like
the chance of walking 460 steps before
falling over is almost nothing if you
just take those trajectories you do
Monte Carlo backups and then you do
reasonable policy optimization on it you
can virtually solve the problem like
just by doing even the straight of
importance corrected expect a reward
maximization you can produce policies
that keep it up for 250 if you now use
like one of these surrogate techniques
you can now you know extract rewards and
keep it up for 400 this is a huge gap
right and this is the max trajectory
witnessed in the training data so you
get this huge improvement gap right
between what the data is showing you
from the monte carlo returns and what
we're able to produce the reason i'm
emphasizing this is what's going on here
is the the feature representation used
here wasn't a neural net just linear it
was just a coordinates to the raw
feature representation the point i want
to make is the raw feature
representation it generalizes wildly and
generalization is our friend we want to
generalize you have very sparse data we
want to infer something from that data
that we've got to apply in a much
broader range of context we want to
generalize but if you use that simple
feature representation in classical
techniques anything that has to do with
Delmon consistency like q-learning or
any variant thereof that feature
representation because it generalizes at
a distance so wildly destabilizes all
bellman Backup based techniques like
literally diverges and what's gone on
now for 20 or 30 years in RL is that the
learning techniques and the feature
techniques that are chosen are chosen to
localize or not generalize value
estimates to stabilize bellman back ups
why are we learning to stabilize bellman
backups we want to generalize and these
two things have been in opposition and
it's the the commitment to bellman
consistency that I think has been
holding us back and pretty
straightforward things start to seem
viable if you just allow yourself to
consider it that's it okay I think
that's enough
[Applause]
what do you think of the migration for
positive animation well at least that
one you know
linear like it's an affine I mean the
other thing we know is that on policy
methods are liked by their nature data
inefficient right and it does seem crazy
to take all this data and chuck it or
even correct it
to be honest I'm not betting on that
direction but I'm not saying it's it's
not reasonable or viable I think that's
another yeah so the things about like
feasibility and so on and so forth those
questions are much easier in though
I guess just kind of they go with that
so I just wanted to first understand
then you say what kind of policy
operations you really mean doing like
the bigger updates as Polly situation
but you're not just talking about
something like the process big steps I
want to just say yes but actually I
don't think that's right so it is like
reinforce except that it's like
reinforced where we're not using the
Rhian we're saying we want to optimize
the policy to maximize expected return
same is reinforced it's just that we're
changing two things we're changing the
optimization objective and we're
changing the missing data inference
mechanism you can think of that it's one
thing but we're changing those two
things that helps reinforced was
effectively that blue line now this is
also off policy so we buy reinforce I
mean importance corrected blah blah blah
reinforce yeah so I'd say yeah trying to
do that but use these other also ask if
your answer was yes was that we know
that we don't at least normally the our
policy setting use reinforce as we do
use these on policy Thurman equations to
reduce variance and so on and so yeah
they should probably I guess be brought
into the mix here as well yes yes it's a
that's a bigger side development to kind
of yeah
but yeah so like the OTR Pio or sort of
procs things are reasonable like you
know just from an optimization
perspective building approximate or like
a trust region is almost independent of
the objective like it's sort of an
orthogonal consideration whether you
want to get into soft actor critic and
we you know really do have a separate
model and we're interested in policy
though difference yeah I guess that's
kind of a side that's sure I'm not
betting on that to be honest but it's
like yeah that's